tesla zooms past 700 billion dollars of
market value after nearly hitting 500
000 deliveries in 2020 they missed it by
what 450 cars
i believe to say exact they sold for
they moved 499
550 deliveries in 2020.
elon musk exceeds his product production
uh target you know he
fell short briefly so proud of the tesla
team for achieving the major milestone
musk tweeted at
the start of tesla i thought we had
optimistically a 10
chance of surviving at all tesla stock
prices soared by more than 740 percent
in 2020 a ton of stuff is being said
about tesla right now we know this
progress but i want to go to the michael
brewery tweet
michael murray of the big short confirms
he's shorting tesla back in september
burry tweeted about tesla's loft
evaluation and said the company relies
on regulatory credit sales
rather than auto sales to turn a profit
in december
bury confirmed on twitter that he is
also putting his money where his mouth
is
so uh on twitter at elon musk
yes i'm short tsla tesla
but some free advice for a good guy
seriously this is he's saying to elon
issue 20 to
25 to 50 of your shares at the current
ridiculous prize that's not delusion
you'd be cementing permanence and untold
optionality if there are buyers sell
that tesla
souffle bury tweeted tuesday night the
tweet was
deleted since musk's warnings the
souffle mentioned was a reference to
warning must
issued this week to tesla employees the
tesla stock price
will immediately get crushed like a
souffle under a sledgehammer
if tesla doesn't reach the profit for a
profitability wall street
has already priced into the stock and
musk famously tweeted that tesla stock
price is too high my honest opinion back
in may of first
tesla stock price is roughly quadruple
seven months since that warning written
in december so what's going on over here
with tesla it's gonna crash this year
there's no way it won't i mean
he is the flavor of the month anything
you do about
elon musk right now is a big story yeah
you know okay
he thought the company had a chance of
going under now it's worth 700 billion
by the way it went up five percent
yesterday so what's that you're thinking
that's no big deal that's 35 billion
that it just went up yesterday i this is
the christian bale
character we're talking about in the
short right this guy knows what's up oh
he knows
oh my god i mean this guy's this guy's a
doctor he's a genius
i i like elon musk i like him as a pop
culture character
yeah i think he's one of the most genius
minds that we've ever created on this
planet
what he's doing with spacex what he's
doing with the the boring company
drilling these huge holes in big cities
and getting rid of traffic
but this is ridiculous and you don't
have to have a finance degree to realize
this is quicksand
this is going to dis and here's the
other thing what if it did
dissipate in value by 50 wouldn't that
still be a win
for a guy who thought his company was
going to go under if it was only worth
350 billion are you are you speculating
are you saying this year they could drop
50
i'm saying it very well could happen
especially with a democratic
house of representatives yeah president
who knows where we're going to be after
today
barring the results of georgia but this
is just fairy dust this is crazy you
throw out these numbers they're not even
real
he's a pop culture character larger than
life a genius
but this doesn't make sense for tesla no
way can they sustain this type of value
yeah i'm seeing these i mean we've
talked about elon musk this isn't
basically this entire year i mean
nobody's had he's the number one
business person of the year for
2020 according to fortune magazine his
fortune has literally
gone from what 30 billion to over a
hundred he's the second richest man
he's gone from like not even in the top
20 or barely in the top 20 to number one
yep um but just a couple of things you
know
you ever seen like the movie the big
lebowski yes when they're like i don't
think you can do this big lebowski
you're a loser the basket he's like
that's like your opinion man so that's
kind of where i'm at
with with tom over here i'm like that's
just like your opinion man
like i that's that's just the first
thing that came to mind so
um total g i mean l
let's just look at the numbers unless
i'm interpreting this wrong and all by
speaking of
like your opinion man the the guy
michael berry i mean he's got a pretty
credible opinion but
again one opinion there's a lot of
people saying that you should short
tesla but the people who are riding the
wave are obviously making money
but here's the number i'm looking at
they said that their their
production target was 500 000 vehicles
and they hit that number
they said they were off by a couple
hundred cars but sometimes they
um they're slightly conservative with
their numbers so the numbers could vary
elon's got 300 in his garage to get that
number up
but like how at this point how do you
bet
against elon musk with everything that
he's doing i remember we had
uh in one of the first podcast pat do
you remember this we said
and this is when elon musk man was like
barely in the top 20 billionaires i mean
he wasn't
like where he is right now it's been a
you know amazing run he's got this year
and we said who would you
bet on who who who's the number one yeah
stock elijah
bezos here and elon and i was like no
i'm going with i'm going with bezos he's
from miami miami guy but at this point
how do you bet against elon musk like
you said he's a pop culture icon but
yeah i agree with you on that
but he's also a freaking genius and he's
delivering well let me ask you this if
you're watching this right now thumbs up
thumbs up if tesla stock goes up this
could actually be a lot of thumbs down
thumbs down if you think tesla stock
could go down okay yeah this in 2021
will it go up or will it go down here's
a couple things to be thinking about
here's a couple things to be thinking
about
you mentioned biden okay you mentioned
it's going to be a democratic
administration etc etc does the left
lean pro gas or does the left lean
pro uh electric car for sure green so so
perfect so that benefits
a tesla right number two
uh we had tom on last week when we were
talking about
ge not ge gm talking about the fact that
hey
everything about now is electric he
showed the website he showed all this
stuff and
you know added there i don't know what
the number was some 20 million cars that
they sold
you know a small minuscule percentage
was what
electric but they said by 2025 all of
cadillac's gonna be what
electric and then by 2030 they're pretty
much making cadillac in
all 100 electric car that's crazy for
general motors to be deciding to do
something like that right
okay what advantage does he have
here's the advantage that he has what's
zuck worth
god knows what the guy is worth facing
what is it 100 million
what is the chances of somebody being
able to create the next facebook to beat
facebook
zero okay i don't know if it's zero but
it's point zero zero zero zero zero
closest thing to
zero which i'm with you where are you
okay so what is the chance of somebody
building an electric car and competing
i don't think it's zero no but but i
think it's higher than
you know maybe say five percent that you
can make something and compete
the automotive business kind of like the
bottling industry or like the
soda business like to compete with coke
and pepsi very difficult certain
industries to get in and compete with
right okay
i think the advantage he has is
he came and said this is the future
and he took the lead and he indirectly
with all the different
charging places he has nationwide and
different places in europe the guy's got
a
semi-monopoly going on where you have to
all reads low to test
lead to tesla is it battery is it
equipment
is it char somehow some way you got to
go through tesla
does that mean this thing's going to
grow the way it's grown right now i
don't know here's the other thing i will
add what how test
with how he is last week we talked about
it tom
where tim cook announced his car apple
stock goes up 103 billion
dollars in one day just because he
dropped the ward car in there
right and the icard the icard
so i think the guy's a visionary i think
the guys killed it this year i have i
have no idea how it's going to be in
2021
but i think everything is on his side
including a biden
administration would be on his side yes
let me follow up with a question to you
because i know
you're you're kind of on the short side
of things
are we talking about 2021 are we talking
for the next decade as an example
because if it's 20 20. great question i
can see it you know going down
over the next 10 years i'm a huge
believer in electric cars and tesla and
everything that even you said gm is
doing clearly we're on the path to that
clearly so if it's one year you may be
right but 10 years
the bar's been raised to such a level
where what if it did go down 20 or 30
does that mean he's not a success he's
still a huge success that's the thing
but he will be judged on this stock
price i i secretly don't think that he
wants the stock price this high
what what's it to benefit him there's a
couple other factors number one
production
how many of these cars can you
legitimately produce per year they
have to create more factories 500 000
isn't that many cars
and they pushed it to the limit with a
huge fourth quarter to get to that
number
apple's coming into the game so is china
china has
three electric car manufacturing
companies
they have 1.3 billion people which
surprisingly
tesla is moving strong into china
they're having success
in china but i in my opinion i think it
all comes down to the battery
because when you think about apple when
you think about apple getting into the
computer game they have their own
systems right they had their own uh word
you know they have their own business
documents their own software which put
them ahead of the game of ibm
if they can sum whoever controls this
battery because if you can get a
universal battery that works with
multiple different types of cars you
don't just have to have a tesla
tesla might be out priced for some
people especially when the traditional
car makers are getting into the game
and you get and you get a like a lower
model which there already are some but
it's unfair to elon musk this stock
price because it is going to go down
and people are going to think that he's
a failure because of it i don't think
they are though i don't think that's the
conversation i think the conversation
right now is the following
i he he's he's built
multiple companies and he's been
successful okay you know there are
certain people
that four of them kisses for them okay
there are certain
you get to a certain status in your life
where you earn saint status
same status as that doesn't mean you if
you if you do like an o.j simpson 2000
yards in a season you know you go out
there and become the
leading russian then you do something
that you did i'm sorry that same status
is gone
forever right but he's insane status
today he has to really screw
up and do something stupid in his
personal life to lose that you're giving
him
status oh he's not done at once no no
i'm sorry
there is no other elon musk in america
in the world today there is no other
elon musk in the world
you're taking musk over bezos back to
our first couple of three companies yes
he's right
i'm not i'm not putting any anybody
ahead of this guy here
nobody uh i don't put anybody hit him i
tell you i think bezos is enjoying life
more than elon musk is
think so i think bezos is a happier
individual than musk is
musk's brain is going a million miles an
hour and it's tough to kind of enjoy
yourself at times right
when you're going like that but let me
make my point to you here's basic math
okay their top line revenue in 2020
the the last number they have in
september they don't have all of it but
in 2020
28.7 1.7 billion dollars their revenue
is up 15.38
their revenue is at 15.38 let me say
this one more time
the revenue is only up 15.38 percent
year-over-year say 20 they're up okay by
the way they finish
2020 with their last report the revenue
is up only 20
but the value is up for x okay let me
say that one more time your revenue goes
up
20 but the value of the company is up
four times that much so what's off that
so
so all michael murray is saying is maybe
it's not the time right now to
long this thing maybe it's good to show
them maybe you come back on a couple
years from now
that's what he's saying michael's not a
lightweight so it's not like you know
you you take who a elon musk is and you
take a michael bury michael
is great at what he does for him to be
able to predict you know
what was going to happen with real
estate market everybody said this guy's
out of his mind
go all these big names looked at him and
laughed at him and he ended up being
right and they made a movie about him
and guess what he's the one guy he hates
doing interviews
he turns on all interviews if you get an
interview with michael bury
you got lucky he doesn't like the camera
he doesn't like to talk
he doesn't he doesn't like the voice to
do a lot of energy just kind of wants to
be
by himself in an office so for him to
say that the data
validates michael bury is right the
numbers prove
michael bury is right for 2021 why did
he delete the tweet though
because he is a non-confrontational guy
he just
doesn't want limelight he doesn't want
the spotlight and it brought
more than he thought you don't know what
sometimes you're having a drink
oh you know you're not going to tweet it
you should tweet it on your twitter you
don't know what happened no one knows
the context
that's you and your buddy right yes
exactly yeah he's a genius when you
watch that movie it'd be interesting to
see what else he
jumped on in the last 12 or 13 years
since the real estate market but
i mean this is kind of common sense
there's just no way it can sustain this
i don't think
math math is not on the alongside math
is not on elon's side
but social capital is on elon's side the
world is banking on this guy
period kai uh so i think elon musk is
one of the few if not the only
to uh help create or co-found four
billion billion
yes you have paypal tesla spacex and
solar that's like danielle day-lewis i
forgot that he was involved in paypal
yeah that's like oh it's okay give me
the company again paypal
tesla spacex solar city oh solar city
what's solarcity solar panel energy yeah
and
he also has the neurolink neuralink oh
he's just boring company he's just
getting started
he's just getting started there's not
another elon musk in the world why can i
follow a question why do you say that um
bezos is enjoying life more than musk
well it's it's it's the it's the you
know uh the worried genius
i don't see bezos as a worry genius i
just see bezos as an analytics guy
that's
extremely logical asperger's no emotion
i see that as bezos
is that what he has that that's where i
would categorize because gates was
categorized as that at one point
when you have asperger's you you don't
have emotions
so you're not offended you're not upset
you're just very
much so focused right but i think
bezos is enjoying life more than
musketeers it's like our boy ben shapiro
i think
i think musk is constantly over thinking
about the next thing you want you know
what's funny
is if you go back 20 years and you look
at pictures of
of bezos and musk they look older than
today
they look better now yeah yeah like they
were balding
dollars and the right to yeah the
doctors will do that there's one more
factor with bezos he looks happier now
because
of his new girlfriend lauren sanchez i
mean he's a different man
because she is a a sexual beast that you
could just tell
damn tom i was at her 30th day doing it
for you all right
so you know but she's you can just tell
he's
invigorated by her presence and he's
enjoying life he's taking her all over
the world
he seems like a happier guy that's what
i you know and maybe some
other of these other things that he's
accomplished in life has slid down the
ladder a little bit more because
why not enjoy the wealth like i was
driving around beverly hills a few weeks
ago with a friend of mine he said hey
there's bezos house hey there's another
one
he has houses all over the place
everywhere i mean you don't even know i
mean
why not enjoy it yeah you know at some
point and he's gonna have another 20
years to enjoy it
twice basis
yeah remember that you you know what
city has the
uh highest average life expectancy in
the world
what city in in the world you can't say
it i say it's a european
country if you see me do the video you
can't say it i haven't seen anything
okay so which city
i'm gonna say it's uh zurich
okay what are you gonna say so random
two things are popping in my mind
somewhere in in greece with the
mediterranean diet or possibly
uh some place in japan it's interesting
how you say you because you went into
people i'm just gonna have fun and i'm
you know i'm just gonna
you know dance and drink and party what
what city is the richest city in the
world with the
monaco monaco monaco's life expectancies
the highest in the world 89 and a half
years
the average person lives 89 and a half
yeah because they're all freaking
billionaires
the point is when you have money you get
the best health care because that's what
you do so
i think he's going to be living a long
time but not if you eat those lobster
rolls bro that'll set you back that
lobster all i
can but ridiculous yeah so okay i mean
look i'm banking
on elon i think we're all saying we're
banking on elon long term tesla
i don't know the math is not on their
side in 22. it's funny though he's got
four other fallback companies if this
thing does take a dive at all and he's
got the tequila coming out yeah
so question for tom how are you who's
lauren sanchez why are you at her 30th
birthday
and why do you know that she's a
quote-unquote sexual beast i don't know
any of that
because it's like like your opinion man
my friend was dating her so why was that
her 30th birthday
yeah it was interesting okay who is she
lauren sanchez that's jeff bezos
no i got that part but who is former
news anchor phoenix la
um you know extra so yeah good good girl
i mean cool fun guys how did that happen
with those two
basils they they were neighbors you know
they they live next to each other in
beverly hills he's got 12 houses and she
was married to the guy that ran
a caa no william morris yeah the co-ceo
william morris well shout out to
uh bezos's ex-wife mackenzie scott she
gives giving money
she's now worth 60 billion yeah and
she's giving away billions and billions
of dollars during the pandemic
so shout out to her i have a lot of
respect for that because
i mean i don't know if you guys feel the
same way like the whole ex-wife thing
they do nothing
sometimes and they just kind of like
live a life of luxury because they
married some rich dude
and they go shopping and they kind of
live there just pissed off three percent
of our audience yeah yeah i'm sorry
ladies
uh but you know they just kind of live
that rodeo jive lifestyle they go
shopping they you know
but to see this lady that's worth this
much is giving away her money and
and and giving back i got a lot of
respect is there a strategy behind your
compliment
yeah mackenzie scott how are you
recruiting how you doing mackenzie's
imagine adam and mackenzie scott
yeah i actually adam goes overnight from
being more 30 billion and he's giving us
videos how to be a billionaire
you know pat listen you got to listen up
here buddy there's a little podcast
thing you got going on
that's a business decision isn't it
we're buying itunes tomorrow you know
you can run a podcast i'm gonna buy a
pot yes
she gave away 6 billion and she's still
probably worth 8 billion more than when
she started
this this might deviate from the topic a
little bit but it's going to stay you
know in miami
speaking of this i asked girls this
question oh
are you a diner no no not that i asked
girl i say ladies
question for you you have two options
would you rather
be with a wealthy wealthy
dude you never have to work again in
your life you're living the high life
you're living in a mansion
you're driving a you know whatever car
you want you got all the like
life is good but this dude is busted
he's gross he's fat he's sloppy he's
bald like the whole thing
right you know or you're living with
some dude
you're with a guy total you know
stud six-pack yeah like you know
macho man sexual you know the whole
thing
but he's broke his [ __ ] and he lives
with his parents who do you pick
and you see these girls brains like
but the guy's got the money and then
he's with this guy
they can't compute a lot of times and
then finally do you know what the most
common response is
i'll just take the rich guy [ __ ] it like
that's what they settle on
but if you ask all the guys in this room
would you be with a wealthy
older sloppy lady or a hot supermodel
who's broke
what are you picking both both this guy
says you're obviously picking the hot
chick right
is it even a question tom might want the
old lady i don't know who you picking
i'm taking
the hot chick obviously what's the
processing
the guys are obviously visual creatures
and we don't care what like
how often do you actually care what the
girl does
i disagree really i disagree who you're
going with the old rich lady no i
disagree what i disagree with you is
a guy is a mentally is an earner and
provider
so to him he takes the responsibility of
being an earner and provider
correct and a a woman depending on what
her priorities in her life are looks at
it as i need a
someone that gives me protection safety
responsibility security and the guy
that's good looking is probably going to
be smashing 10 other girls at the same
time as you so
you're sharing your guys so there is so
yeah so the guy of course you're going
to go with the yeah a 40 guy you're
going to go because i'm going to go work
i'm going to go make my money yes i want
to be with the hot girl i don't need you
to bring your bills you agree with me
except i think you ought to consider a
strategy with mckenzie
i think for you believe me i've got some
calls out to her okay thank you
mackenzie please return a call i think
you got to consider something like that
for you
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]